J'applique le deuxième ensemble à la mêlée sur le
rebord mamita que suceda généalogie avec
navami Lopez antique faire des taches sur le
sélecteur venir est une question de famille
premier magasin d'armes à feu zoom numérique est un
centre de recherche de banc solitaire à amelia
nude est à l'origine de nouveaux
amateurs d'asymétries américaines conduit détourner un  la pauvre Hillary
Clinton marinella sale reçoit un
pays pauvre équitable Don ultra un adulte keynote
vodka sauce pour pâtes Santa Fe concession
esta tarde avance sur TT
avez-vous fait votre choix pour une
semaine eh bien oui eh bien nous ne pouvons pas nous concentrer
sur le document et comme je '  je suis dans une
procédure silencieuse donc mais je pense que
ce sont des gens pas ouais l'entreprise
ouais parce qu'ils sont toujours petits comme God
LLC qui est une société à responsabilité limitée
donc nous allons déposer nos
facteurs de vente sur la masse salariale pour la protection à
travers l'entreprise  c'est en fait une sorte
de faille dans le système qui est
plus facile d'être propriétaire d'une entreprise, vous êtes
sans papiers et d'être un travailleur parce que
vos travailleurs n'ont pas encore travaillé plusieurs fois
sous la table honnêtement, les deux personnes
qui sont montrées sur grand écran, je
pense qu'elles ne devraient pas être ne sont pas la bonne
représentation de ce que les États-Unis devraient être
quelle est la réalité de votre famille puisque
vous êtes le seul qui était  né ici
et ils sont tous sans papiers Je suis toujours
traité comme un sans papiers même si je
suis né et j'ai grandi ici aux États-Unis ouais
comme je le fais et comment était-ce ainsi pour moi comme
par exemple l'université on m'a refusé le
basket j'étais un couteau  une aide financière
juste à cause des antécédents de mes parents
parce que nous ne savons pas exactement parce
qu'ils sont en lacca mentor et quelle est la
prochaine étape pour eux d'obtenir ces papiers,
ils ont été beaucoup de crimes depuis 23 ans maintenant
et oui et tout le monde continue de
battre  autour du pot et la loi sont
plutôt heureux que mes parents soient venus ici il y a plus de 20
ans du Mexique sans papiers et
donc ils devaient vraiment savoir gratter
et économiser partout où ils le pouvaient et je ne
pense pas que ce soient de vraies leçons que
Trump ait jamais apprises  et nous voyons parce que
Sinon, je ne pense pas qu'il aurait
ciblé la communauté des immigrés tant
la communauté américaine est l'une des communautés les
plus entrepreneuriales et vous
voyez tant de petites entreprises se développer
ici, mais le fait qu'elles soient tellement de
leur faute parce qu'il n'y a tout simplement pas  tout simplement
pas beaucoup de logements de soutien pour
les personnes à faible revenu, je pense que vous
entendez à peine parler de la classe ouvrière ou des travailleurs
pauvres, c'est principalement comme élargir la
classe moyenne et vraiment vous ne pouvez pas le
faire sans avoir une base plus solide dans
la classe ouvrière et c'est ce que
les effets ne font tout simplement pas un meilleur logement équitable
qui a des protections contre
les propriétaires sans scrupules de meilleurs emplois dans
cette économie plus de soutien pour les petites
entreprises comme celle-ci vous n'avez pas
vraiment accès à beaucoup comme ça
quel genre de soutien ouais ouais comme quand
nous avons commencé comme maintenant  c'est notre
septième année dans l'entreprise, mais pendant les
trois premières années, c'était vraiment difficile sur le
plan économique et je pense que plus d'accès aux
emprunts et aux prêts équitables  g
surtout le crédit aurait été
utile